We got warblers, we got cardinals, we got golden eagles now. I do love birds and waterfowl, so. Yeah, oh my goodness, that's correct. That's correct. Bryce, I wasn't even thinking about that. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 45 recorded on September 11th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we revisit inverse scans, talk about groups, and talk a little bit about combinator birds. Maybe that should be an episode one day. Not that people care. Maybe not. I went to three national science fairs.
我们有林莺，我们有红衣主教，我们现在还有金雕。我确实很喜欢鸟类和水禽，所以。是的，哦天哪，那是对的。那是对的。布莱斯，我甚至都没想到这一点。欢迎收看第45集于2021年9月11日录制的播客节目ADSP。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人是布莱斯，我们将重新探讨逆扫描，聊聊群，还要聊聊一点关于组合子鸟的内容。也许有一天这也应该成为一集节目。倒不是说有人在乎。也许不会吧。我去过三个全国科学展。
Yeah, that's definitely going to be an episode. do i not i i keep learning things about connor and you know it's i've learned enough surprising things about connor that i'm never surprised when i learn some new savant level thing that connor has done it's not savant although Although I will say this, the start of the story was that I had no intention on trying to get to the national level. I just one year, I asked my mom, how come when people break their spinal cords, they can't like fix it like you break your arm, you put a cast on it, you're good to go. But like you break your spinal cord. And then you're in a wheelchair for the rest of your life either as a paraplegic or quadriplegic and uh she was like well why don't you do a science fair project on it and uh fast forward like a couple years later i had finished cutting up some worms and like testing how they regenerated their cells and all this stuff and i was just this like happy-go- I had, I had, uh, finished all my projects in a woodworking elective. And so I cut out like a sort of mini life-size human, and then plugged in a bunch of Christmas lights to like different parts of the body. And very,
对，那绝对会成为一集节目。我怎么——我不断地在了解关于康纳的新鲜事，你知道的，我已经对康纳有了足够的惊人了解，所以我听到康纳做出了什么新的学者级成就时，我一点也不惊讶，这倒不是说我是个天才，不过——不过我要说的是，这个故事的开头是我根本没打算冲刺到全国赛。只是有一年，我问我妈，为什么当人们的脊髓断裂时，他们不能像骨折那样把骨头接好，打上石膏，然后就万事大吉了呢？但是像脊髓断裂这种事，然后你下半辈子就得坐轮椅，要么高位截瘫，要么四肢瘫痪，然后呢——她说，那你为什么不做个关于这个的科学展项目呢？然后呢——时间快进几年后，我已经切碎了一些虫子，测试了它们是如何再生细胞的，诸如此类的一大堆东西，我当时就是这样一个快乐的——我有，我当时在木工选修课里做完了所有的项目。所以我剪出了一个差不多真人大小的迷你模型，然后在身体的不同部位插了一串圣诞彩灯。而且非常，
very unsafely had this mechanism where I could plug and unplug these little things. And so it would light up like, Oh, if you break it at l4 like at lumber 4 like this is the parts that you lose access to it was super awesome and definitely against all the regulations uh and then any i ended up i ended up getting one of the top awards which involved a entrance to the canada-wide science fair which at the the time was that year being held in St. John's, Newfoundland on the other side of the country. Connor Hoekstra in grade eight had never stepped foot on a plane before. I had not, I had not traveled like outside of the province. I don't think in my lifetime, maybe I crossed the U S border once, but I'd never flown, um, never been on a plane. Well, I guess those are the same thing, but you never know.
非常不安全地设计了一个机制，我可以把这些小东西插上和拔下来。所以它就会亮起来，哦，如果你在l4也就是腰椎第4节弄断了的话，这就是你会失去感觉的部位，这超级棒，而且绝对违反了所有的规定——然后无论如何，我最后——我最后拿到了顶级奖项之一，其中包含一张加拿大全国科学展的入场券。当时的那个科学展在那一年是在圣约翰斯举办的，纽芬兰在国家的另一头。八年级的康纳·霍克斯特拉（Connor Hoekstra）以前从未踏上过飞机。我没有，我没有去过——像省外旅行。在我的一生中好像都没有，也许我穿过一次美国边境，但我从来没坐过飞机，嗯，从来没坐过飞机。好吧，我猜这两者是一回事，但你永远说不准。
And so I was so excited. I walked down the whatever the stage, the auditorium down to the stage. I was literally like shaking and jumping up and down. And all I was thinking in my head, like literally all the other winners, they're just standing there with their like trophy. I am like bouncing up and down on the stage like a small bunny rabbit, like an Energizer bunny. And in my head, I'm thinking, oh, my God, I hope my parents let me go. Oh, my God, I hope my parents let me go because I wasn't sure if I was going to be allowed to go. But it was all expenses paid.
所以我当时太激动了。我走过那个什么——舞台，穿过礼堂走上舞台。我简直就像在发抖，又蹦又跳。我脑子里想的全是，真的，所有其他的获奖者，他们只是站在那里拿着奖杯。而我在舞台上像一只小兔子一样蹦上跳下，就像一只精力充沛的电池兔子。我脑子里在想，噢天哪，我希望我爸妈能让我去。噢天哪，我希望我爸妈能让我去，因为我当时不确定自己是否被允许去。但那是全包销的。
And, yeah, that was a good time. They fly your parents out too, I assume. No, no, no. You, uh, you go with the chaperone. Um, and yeah, Chris Gayski, uh, he, he did his on a genetics project on genetics at the time. And so, yeah, we became good friends. Um, and I was supposed to go travel around with him in Europe. He was doing his MBA in the Netherlands in the past year. And then good old COVID. Good old COVID. He was doing an MBA in the Netherlands in the past year. And then good old COVID.
而且，是的，那是一段美好的时光。我猜他们也会给你父母买机票飞过去吧？不，不，不。你，呃，你是跟带队老师一起去的。然后，是的，克里斯·盖斯基（Chris Gayski），呃，他，他当时做的是一个关于遗传学、关于遗传学的项目。所以，是的，我们成了好朋友。然后，我本打算和他一起在欧洲旅游。过去一年里他在荷兰读MBA。然后，老朋友新冠。老朋友新冠。过去一年里他在荷兰读MBA。然后，老朋友新冠。
Good old COVID. He's doing an MBA in the Netherlands? Yeah, yeah. He is. It would have been awesome to go and travel around. But well, so we ended up talking a little bit about the associative operation back in episode 43. Then episode 44, completely unplanned. We just ended up opining.
老朋友新冠。他在荷兰读MBA？对，对。他是的。能去到处旅游本来会很棒的。不过，好吧，我们在第43集中稍微讨论了结合律运算。然后在第44集中，完全没有计划。我们最后只是在发表高见。
We might have to do another episode. I think the moral is if you're in school, 43, then episode 44, completely unplanned. We just ended up opining. We might have to do another episode. I think the moral is if you're in school, probably the answer for most of you is to stay in school. Should you go to school? Stay tuned for a future episode, which I guess at that point will be planned. I was going to bring up one last thing, which maybe I should cut into the first one because it's math related. So we we in episode 42 had you had mentioned there's probably a name for the mathematical property of the difference between the plus and the max scan. And then we put it to our listeners.
我们可能得再录一集。我认为其中的道理是，如果你还在上学，第43集，然后是第44集，完全没有计划。我们最后只是在发表高见。我们可能得再录一集。我认为其中的道理是，如果你还在上学，你们大多数人的答案大概是继续留在学校。你应该上学吗？敬请期待未来的某一集，我猜到那时就会有计划了。我还要提最后一件事，也许我应该把它剪到第一部分去，因为它跟数学有关。所以我们在第42集中，你曾提到，关于加法扫描和最大值扫描之间差异的数学性质，可能有一个名字。然后我们把它交给了听众们。
So one of our listeners responded via tweet. His name or their name, I should say is andre andreas shati i apologize we gotta we gotta do take a course on how to like pronounce names i don't i don't think that would help us i don't think i think it would i'm gonna whatever affliction we have when it comes to pronunciation i don't think it's curable uh at me on on twitter or github if there's a course i can take but um they wrote i believe the concept you're searching uh was inverse functions a function is invertible if it is a bijection uh in the case of scans don't consider the binary operation but instead consider the partially applied unary function so for example if you have 42 plus X, or the max of 42 X, addition is obviously
于是我们的一个听众通过推特回复了。他的名字，或者说他们的名字，我应该说是安德烈·阿德里安·沙蒂（Andre Andreas Shati），我很抱歉，我们得——我们得开个课程学习怎么发音名字，我不知道——我不觉得那会对我们有帮助，我不觉得，我真的觉得。不管我们在发音方面有什么毛病，我觉得它是治不好的。呃，如果在推特或GitHub上有我可以上的课程，请艾特我，但是，呃，他们写道：我相信你们一直在寻找的概念是逆函数。如果一个函数是双射的，它就是可逆的。在扫描的情况下，不要考虑二元运算，而是考虑部分应用的一元函数。所以举个例子，如果你有42加X，或者42和X的最大值，加法很显然是
bijective, but max isn't because in this example, all values of X that are less than or equal to 42 are mapped to 42. Whereas for plus, it's not the case. So like it's a one to one mapping for a unary function. So like basically, you can think of max as like it sucks in, it maps a bunch of different values, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, all the way to 42 into 42. And so because of that, you can't get back those values. But for a function like 42 plus x, whenever you have a different value of x, it's always going to produce a different answer. I'm not sure if bijection is actually what we're looking for. So I guess they're saying it's inverse functions. That being said, we also got a response
双射的，但最大值不是，因为在这个例子中，所有小于或等于42的X值都被映射到了42。而对于加法来说，情况并非如此。所以它对一元函数来说是一对一的映射。所以基本上，你可以把最大值想象成——它吞进去了，它把一堆不同的值，1、2、3、4、5、6、7，一直到42，全部映射成了42。正因为如此，你无法找回那些值。但对于像“42加x”这样的函数，每当你有不同的x值时，它总是会产生不同的答案。我不确定双射是否真的是我们在找的东西。所以我想他们说的是逆函数。话虽如此，我们还收到了一个回复
on GitHub, and this is from Roman. Explain how we got a response on GitHub. Because I said, if you don't have Twitter, just go find our... So I have... Our website is hosted using Ruby Jekyll pages,
在GitHub上，这是来自罗曼（Roman）的回复。解释一下我们是怎么在GitHub上收到回复的。因为我说过，如果你没有推特，就去找我们的……所以我有一个……我们的网站是用Ruby Jekyll页面托管的，
blogs. And so it's just backed by like a GitHub repo. And so he just opened an issue or they opened an issue. Sorry. I love it. If you have any complaints about our podcast, just open an issue or send us a PR. I've decided that once every 50 episodes, which we're coming up
博客。所以它背后就是一个GitHub仓库。然后他就提了一个Issue（问题），或者他们提了一个Issue。抱歉。我太喜欢了。如果你对我们的播客有任何抱怨，尽管去提个Issue或者给我们发个PR。我决定每50集——我们现在快要到了——
on now, we will quasi-reintroduce ourselves and we'll plug all our contact stuff because I don't really like plugging like, oh, you know, follow us here, blah, blah, blah. If people like it, they'll do whatever. Shouldn't we tell all the people to go leave us reviews on
我们会半重新介绍一下自己，然后我们会宣传我们所有的联系方式，因为我其实不太喜欢宣传诸如“哦，你知道的，去关注我们这里，吧啦吧啦吧啦”之类的话。如果人们喜欢它，他们就会做他们想做的事。难道我们不应该告诉所有人去给我们留个评分吗？
the iTunes store? No. So I just said we're doing that once every 50 episodes. That's the thing. It sort of irks me when I listen to 30-plus podcasts, and they're always saying, you know, go leave a five-star review on iTunes. And I'm like, well, wait. What if I don't like your podcast enough to give a five-star review? And, like, they don't ask. They don like your podcast enough to give a five-star review? And they don't ask.
在iTunes商店里？不。所以我刚才说了，我们每50集才做一次这个。就是这样。当我听了30多个播客，而他们总是说，你知道的，去iTunes上留个五星好评吧，这让我有点烦。然后我就想，等等。如果我不是那么喜欢你的播客，不想给五星好评怎么办？而且，他们不要求。他们不要求——如果你不是那么喜欢你的播客，不想给五星好评怎么办？而且他们不要求。
They don't ask for – some of them ask for a review. But most of them implore you to go give a five-star review. See, the podcasts I listen to are better than the podcasts you listen to because the podcasts I listen to never implore you to leave a five-star review. They just say, please leave a review. Yeah, yeah. That's the thing. I would never ask for a five-star. I would say leave the review that Yeah, yeah. That's the thing. I would never ask for five stars. I would say, leave the review
他们不要求——其中一些人会要求留个评价。但大多数人是恳求你去给个五星好评。你看，我听的播客比你听的播客要好，因为我听的播客从来不会恳求你留个五星好评。他们只会说，请留个评价吧。对，对。就是这样。我绝不会要五星。我会说，留下你认为——对，对。就是这样。我绝不会要五星。我会说，留下你认为
that you think is appropriate. I mean, if you don't like our content, feel, I mean, do what you want. Don't leave a review. Leave a one-star review. You know. Don't leave a one-star review on this podcast. I will find you. I see.
合适的评价。我是说，如果你不喜欢我们的内容，随你的便，我是说，你想怎么样就怎么样。别留评价。留个一星评价吧。你知道的。别在这个播客里留一星评价。我会找到你的。我明白。
That's the thing is, I don't know what the typical listener looks like or what their behavior is like but I feel like if now we're gonna get a bunch of one-star reviews just I'm gonna have to wait do we have do we have reviews on iTunes I have no idea I don't I don't honestly I honestly I my my value from recording this is just getting a chat with you once every, once every couple of weeks. And then every once in a while we have people retweet or whatever, tweet at us on Twitter. I can't, I, now, but now I have to know, now I have to know.
问题就在于，我不知道典型的听众长什么样，或者他们的行为是什么样的，但我感觉如果我们现在会收到一堆一星评价，只是——我得等一下，我们iTunes上有评价吗？我完全不知道，我真的——说实话，我录制这个节目的价值，只是为了每隔几周能跟你聊一次天。然后偶尔有人转发，或者诸如此类，在推特上艾特我们。我不能——现在，但我现在必须知道，现在必须知道了。
Okay. I don't, I, I own no, I own no things from the Apple corporation. So I have no idea how to access the iTunes store, but somebody, please tell me if we have reviews, especially if they're like really bad reviews that like, just like trash us. Like, I want to know. I want to know. Oh man. If you want, if you want bad reviews, we can just go look at one of my YouTube videos. The ones where I do like the comparative languages. Oh, man.
好吧。我没有——我没有任何苹果公司的东西。所以我完全不知道怎么访问iTunes商店，但是，请谁告诉我我们有没有评价，尤其是如果它们是非常糟糕、把我们批得一文不值的评价——我就想知道。我想知道。哦天哪。如果你想——如果你想看差评，我们大可以去看看我的某个YouTube视频。就是那些我做语言对比的视频。哦天哪。
I get a lot of hate these days. It's just like, you know, yeah. We'll save it for another episode. But, yes, we did get an issue opened by Roman Koshitsyn. Koshitsyn. Well, you know, we should tell people, you know we should tell people you know if you have if you have you know if you find some issue or you have some feedback
这些天我招来很多骂。就好像，你知道的，是的。我们把它留到以后的一集再讲吧。但是，是的，我们确实收到了罗曼·科希津（Roman Koshitsyn）提的一个Issue。科希津。好吧，你知道的，我们应该告诉大家，你知道我们应该告诉大家，你知道如果你有——如果你有——你知道如果你发现了什么问题或者有什么反馈
or something like you can open an issue but you could also like send us a PR with an audio clip of you asking the question something like that and then we can use it in the episode can they do that on a github issue uh how are they sending us i don't i'm gonna remind you of the relationship here i'm the
或者类似的东西，你可以提一个Issue，但你也可以给我们发一个PR，里面带一段你提问的音频剪辑，诸如此类的内容，然后我们就可以把它用在节目里。他们能在GitHub的Issue里这么做吗？呃，他们是怎么发给我们的？我——我在这里提醒你一下我们的关系，我是
executive producer i come up with the big ideas you implement them so the problem is is that we deck we technically do have an email but but I already have six personal emails. I do not have the bandwidth to keep track of another email. Just have it forward to your Gmail. That's what I do. That's a lot of work. No, no, no. It's really easy to set up.
执行制作人，我提出伟大的想法，你来负责实现它们。所以问题在于，我们技术上确实有一个电子邮箱，但是我已经有六个个人邮箱了。我实在没有精力再去追踪另一个邮箱了。直接转发到你的Gmail不就行了。我就是这么干的。那工作量太大了。不，不，不。设置起来真的很简单。
That's what I do. All right. Yeah, I'll show you how to do it. Yeah. Well, think about it. Anyways, we got to read this. We got to read this. And I've realized it actually was not not the issue was not opened by Roman.
我就是这么干的。好吧。好吧，我会教你怎么弄的。好吧，再想想吧。不管怎样，我们得读一下这个。我们得读一下这个。而且我意识到实际上并不是——这个Issue不是罗曼提的。
It was opened by Sunbubble. And then Roman just posted a comment, which actually I didn't even see because it was posted seven hours ago. So very quickly, Sunbubble says, I'm pretty sure that the concept you're looking for is group. So we've got inverse functions and we've got group. A group is just a monoid with
它是由Sunbubble提的。然后罗曼只是发了一条评论，其实我都没看到，因为那是七小时前发的。所以非常快地，Sunbubble说，我非常确凿地认为你们在找的概念是“群”。所以我们有了逆函数，我们现在还有了“群”。一个群只是一个带有
an additional inverse operation for each element of the set. My understanding is that the inverse left scan is just a monoid with an additional inverse operation for each element of the set my understanding is that the inverse left scan is just a right scan with the inverse binary operation actually wait my understanding is that the inverse left scan is just a right scan with the inverse binary operation is that true so a a plus scan is the left scan and an inverse of that, they're saying, is a right scan with the inverse, which would be minus. So that would be that would be correct. Technically. Yeah, technically, that is, I think, correct. It's correct for the plus scan, like a plus an inverse plus scan is equivalent to a
集合中每个元素的额外逆运算的幺半群。我的理解是，逆左扫描只是一个带有逆二元运算的右扫描——事实上，等等，我的理解是逆左扫描只是一个带有逆二元运算的右扫描，这是真的吗？所以，一个加法扫描是左扫描，而它的逆，他们说，是一个带有逆运算的右扫描，也就是减法。所以那将是——那将是正确的。从技术上讲。是的，从技术上讲，我认为那是正确的。它对于加法扫描是正确的，比如加法和一个逆加法扫描等价于一个
minus right scan but is it is it correct for all the other ones sun bubble sun bubble continues to say keep in mind that both monoids and groups may or may not be commutative related to the missing reduction episode topic also as far as i know monoid or maybe strictly a semi group is the typical base property you need to be able to implement a parallel version of scans and folds. And then Sunbubble links a couple resources. And the Roman replies, I've just listened to episode 42 and found this repo to say groups, groups are everywhere, but Sunbubble beat me. Let me elaborate a bit more on this. A group is a pair of an operation and a set. This means that existence of inverse often depends not only on the operation you use,
减法右扫描，但它——但它对所有其他运算都正确吗？Sunbubble——Sunbubble继续说道，请记住，幺半群和群可能符合交换律，也可能不符合，这与之前漏掉的归约这一集主题有关。另外，据我所知，幺半群或者可能严格来说是半群，是你实现扫描和折叠的并行版本时所需的典型基础属性。然后Sunbubble链接了一些资源。接着罗曼回复道，我刚听了第42集，发现了这个仓库来谈论群，群无处不在，但Sunbubble比我快了一步。让我对此再多阐述一点。群是一对运算和集合。这意味着逆运算的存在往往不仅取决于你使用的运算，
but also on the type of elements fed into this operation. That makes sense, yeah. And then I'm not going to read through this, but Roman proceeds to say, let's show that, and then states a lemma and has a bit of a proof. At least in terms of C++, when we're talking about an operation um i think we are typically talking about a group because when we're talking about an operation we're not talking about it distinct from you know the types that it operates on like Like when we, okay, you know, sometimes we, we would talk about, you know, a subset of the inputs, like, you know, talking about std reduce on ints, but usually we're talking about like, you know, std reduce on,
还取决于输入到这个运算中的元素的类型。这说得通，是的。然后我就不把这些读完了，但罗曼接着说，让我们来证明这一点，然后陈述了一个引理，并做了一点证明。至少在C++的语境下，当我们谈论一个运算时，呃，我认为我们通常是在谈论一个群，因为当我们谈论一个运算时，我们并不是把它与它所操作的类型分开来谈的——就像当我们——好吧，你知道的，有时我们会——我们会谈论输入的一个子集，就像，你知道的，谈论针对int的std::reduce，但通常我们谈论的是——你知道的，针对——
you know, whether I've, we don't have a concept for the, the requirements that we put on them, but you know, that, that, that, that class of things, you know, forms a set. And, and so then when we talk about like when we talk about stood reduce, we're not just talking about stood reduce, but we're also talking about stood reduce and you know, the sequences that can be fed into stood reduce. Yeah. std reduce and you know the the sequences that can be fed into std reduce yeah looks like i gotta go after finishing this category theory book i gotta go read a set theory book i feel like set theory is actually going to be more useful than category theory if i uh if i find them i can mail you some
不管我有没有，我们对于施加在它们身上的要求没有一个概念，但你知道的，那一类东西，你知道的，构成了一个集合。所以当我们谈论——当我们谈论std::reduce时，我们不仅仅是在谈论std::reduce，我们还在谈论std::reduce和（你知道的）可以输入到std::reduce中的序列。是的，std::reduce以及（你知道的）可以输入到std::reduce中的序列。是的，看来我得去了，在看完这本范畴论的书之后，我得去读一本集合论的书。我觉得集合论实际上会比范畴论更有用，如果我——如果我找到了，我可以把我的——我的一些数学书寄给你。
of my some of my math books okay and we didn't even so my my goal was to talk about the, uh, inverse functions group response and then also the other feedback that we did. And you know, I'm, I'm terrible because I knew that we, I knew that we had that inverse group, uh, uh, cause I saw it on Twitter. I knew we had that. I knew we had it to talk about, but I had to do my ranchy spiel thing. Well, no, so I was going to, I was going to say that was going to be the first episode. And then then the second one was gonna be delving into the world of combinator birds because i've just been going on a combinator tear because i'm reading to to mock a mockingbird and like it used to just be about the starlings and the phoenix and the bluebirds but now we got bald eagles golden eagles we got them all man and uh i'm catching them all and it's it's it's so awesome and it's
好吧，我们甚至都没有——所以我的目标是谈论，呃，逆函数群的回复，然后还有我们做的其他反馈。而且你知道的，我很糟糕，因为我知道——我知道我们有那个逆群，呃，因为我在推特上看到了。我知道我们有这个。我知道我们有这个要聊，但我还是得先发泄一番我的唠叨。好吧，不，所以我要说——那将是第一集。然后第二集将深入探索组合子鸟的世界，因为我一直在进行一场组合子大狂欢，因为我正在读《模仿一只知更鸟》（To Mock a Mockingbird），而且以前它只关乎欧椋鸟、菲尼克斯鸟和蓝知更鸟，但现在我们有了白头鹰、金雕，我们应有尽有，伙计，而且——我把它们全抓齐了，而且这——这太棒了，而且这——
really it's gonna be the future. I don't understand how Haskell Curry spent, you know, three to four decades studying and writing his texts on combinatory logic. And then it just seems like the world's forgotten about it. Like everybody knows about lambda calculus. But what happened to the SKI combinator calculus? That's where it's at. That's where it's at, man. And Martin, or not Martin, Raymond Smullyan, he wrote the book with the birds.
真的，这将是未来。我不明白哈斯克尔·柯里（Haskell Curry）是怎么花了两到三四十年时间去研究并撰写关于组合子逻辑的著作的。然后整个世界似乎就把这事给忘了。就像每个人都知道λ演算一样。但是SKI组合子演算怎么了？那才是精髓所在。那才是精髓所在，伙计。而马丁——或者说不是马丁，雷蒙德·斯穆里安（Raymond Smullyan），他写了那本关于鸟类的书。
It's more fun. Who doesn't want to learn the bird names? Who doesn't want to learn the bird names, Bryce? I put it to the listener. Don't you want to learn about the birds? We got warblers. We got cardinals. We got golden eagles now.
这更有趣。谁不想学习鸟类的名字呢？谁不想学习鸟类的名字，布莱斯？我把它抛给听众。难道你不想了解这些鸟类吗？我们有林莺。我们有红衣主教。我们现在还有金雕。
I do love birds and waterfowl. Yeah. Oh, my goodness. That's correct. That's correct. Bryce, I wasn't even thinking about that. I took a sign about when I was in Regina visiting a friend in August because they had a waterfowl park. And I thought Bryce, this is Bryce. That's actually not Bryce's kind of city because it's really no offense to the people of Regina.
我确实很喜欢鸟类和水禽。是的。哦，天哪。那是对的。那是对的。布莱斯，我甚至都没想到这一点。八月份我在里贾纳（Regina）拜访朋友时看了一个标志，因为那里有一个水禽公园。我想，布莱斯，这就是布莱斯——这其实不太算布莱斯的城市，因为那里真的——对里贾纳的人们没有恶意。
Look, I will. Bryce is usually the one offending people of the world, but I will take a turn. Regina is not a lot going on. I think the I think the lake in the middle of the city like they made that lake. Maybe it was there, but I feel I feel like they made it. But they added a little waterfowl park next to it, and you can't run by a sign that says waterfowl park when you've got a podcast with Bryce and not think of him. And this recording has completely gone off the rails now. I guess we're going to have to do a waterfowl episode. Oh, yeah, yeah. Maybe that's what I'll call if I've decided at some point I guess we're going to have to do it. We're going to have to do a waterfowl episode. A waterfowl episode.
看，我会的。布莱斯通常是那个冒犯世界各地的人的人，但我来轮一次。里贾纳没太多好玩的。我觉得——我觉得市中心中间的那个湖，他们是人工造了那个湖。也许它本来就在那儿，但我感觉——感觉那是他们人工造的。但他们在旁边加了一个小型水禽公园，当你拥有一个和布莱斯合作的播客时，你路过一个写着“水禽公园”的标志，就不可能不想到他。而且这段录音现在彻底脱轨了。我想我们得做一集关于水禽的节目了。哦，对，对。也许这就是我以后要叫的——如果我什么时候决定了，我想我们非得这么做不可。我们得做一集水禽节目。一集水禽节目。
Maybe that's what I'll call. I've decided at some point, spoiler for the listeners, that I will come out of retirement. Spoiler for who? Spoiler for who? You said spoiler for the listeners, but there's not listeners.
也许这就是我以后要叫的。我决定在某个时刻，给听众剧透一下，我会复出。给谁剧透？给谁剧透？你刚才说给听众剧透，但又说没有听众。
There's listeners. For the listener. Thanks there's not listeners. There's listeners. Oh, yes, for the listener. Thanks for listening, listener. We really need to get back in the swing of things. This is a rough ending. This is a rough landing. Yeah, I'll say. You can fix it in post.
有听众的。为了听众。谢谢——有听众的。有听众的。哦，是的，为了听众。谢谢你们的收听，听众。我们真的需要重新进入状态了。这是一个艰难的收尾。这是一个艰难的着陆。是的，我赞同。你可以在后期剪辑里修复它。
All right. Yeah, we should probably call it. Well, we'll wait. What was the spoiler for listener? For the listener? Oh, yeah, that I'm coming out of. I will be at some point in the future. I will come out of my speaking retirement to give a talk on waterfowl.
好吧。是的，我们大概该挂电话了。好吧，等等。刚才对听众的剧透是什么？为了听众？哦，对，就是我要复出。我将在未来的某个时刻。我将结束我的演讲生涯隐退，做一场关于水禽的演讲。
Okay, good. And maybe that's what I'll call it. I'll call it. Maybe I'll call it. Yeah. Bryce's birds or something I don't mind that I don't mind that at all
好吧，很好。也许这就是我要给它起的名字。我叫它。也许我会叫它。对。布莱斯的鸟类或者别的什么，我不介意这个，我一点也不介意这个。
do you have yeah maybe that's an amazing idea that's an amazing idea were you about to ask do I have a favorite waterfowl I was but then I was thinking of actually I'm not sure geese are like geese are like you know geese are pretty good but they're also a little bit terrifying ducks are like ducks are
你有——对，也许这是一个绝妙的主意，这是一个绝妙的主意。你刚才是不是想问我有没有最喜欢的水禽？我是想问的，但接着我在想——其实，我不确定鹅是不是——鹅就像——你知道的，鹅挺不错的，但它们也有点吓人。鸭子就像——鸭子挺——
pretty ducks are pretty okay i'm not sure if there's any of the bird names that correspond to ducks but what would be amazing is if i didn't actually give the talk live and i i pre-recorded it as like a mini documentary where I'm explaining, getting all excited about the combinator birds. And then we cut to like a little tour of a bird sanctuary and Bryce just, oh, look, look, it's a cardinal. And then cuts to the,
鸭子挺不错的，我不确定是不是有任何鸟类的名字对应鸭子。不过最棒的是，如果我其实不是现场演讲，而是把它预先录制成一个迷你纪录片，在片中我一边解释，一边对组合子鸟兴奋不已。然后我们切到一个鸟类庇护所的小游览画面，布莱斯突然说：哦，看，看，是一只红衣主教。然后切回到——
a cardinal is also known as flip from Haskell and it's the C combinator. Cardinals are useful for, we cut back to Bryce. Look, it's a warbler. Perfect, perfect. It would be amazing. Although I'm not sure if we could find, I wonder if there's a bird, what do they call it? Like an aviary or a sanctuary that has all of the birds.
红衣主教在哈斯克尔中也被称为flip，它就是C组合子。红衣主教对于——我们切回布莱斯。看，是一只林莺。完美，完美。这太棒了。虽然我不知道我们能不能找到——我想知道有没有这样一只鸟，他们管这叫什么？比如鸟舍或者拥有所有这些鸟类的庇护所。
New York has everything. So I assume there's an aviary somewhere. Yeah, does it have all the birds, though? Does it have buntings, Picards? New York has everything. So yes, I'm sure it does. Okay. Well, wait, some of them aren't real, though.
纽约应有尽有。所以我假设某处肯定有个鸟舍。是的，不过它有所有的鸟吗？它有彩旗鸟、皮卡德鸟吗？纽约应有尽有。所以是的，我确信它有。好吧。不过等等，其中有些并不是真的，对吧。
Phoenix, that's not a real bird. No, that's not a real bird. Wait, did I click stop? Oh, no, I didn't. Okay, good. All right, I'm clicking stop now. Yes, did you? Because this is all such gold.
菲尼克斯鸟，那不是真的鸟。不，那不是真的鸟。等等，我按停止了吗？哦，不，我没按。好吧，很好。好了，我现在按停止了。是的，你按了吗？因为这些全都是宝贝啊。
Such gold. We'll really be able to use this. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
全都是宝贝。我们真的能用上这些。谢谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。